called for targeting gone for the rest  of the game  and the sooners go the rest of the way  to take the early lead  mims right here you've got to defend  deep shots with oklahoma  rattler looks like he wants to launch  one deep he's going deep  and has the touchdown  great call by lincoln riley and by todd  black lynch it's 45 yards  mims right here you've got to defend  deep shots with oklahoma  rattler looks like he wants to launch  one deep he's going deep  and has the touchdown  great call by lincoln riley and by todd  black lynch it's 45 yards  drake stoops watch the block he gets  right here on the linebacker hummel  that's going to spring his quarterback  to the end zone he's a  feisty tough little blocker and he gets  the key block there  and spencer rattler gets the touchdown